what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and
everything related to the marvel
cinematic universe or i should probably
start saying multiverse because
spider-man no way home and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
are going to really start to blow things
up multiverse wise i mean obviously it's
called multiverse of madness but just
what are we in for in the future if you
are thinking that marvel is going to be
the same they are not and in a very very
good way they're changing things up in a
great way and the scale of which they're
doing their movies now has been
heightened the bar has been raised and
movies like the eternals xiang chi
spider-man no way home multiverse of
madness these are all going to be huge
films and then we're going to have the
disney plus series kind of be the ones
that are a little bit more toned down
although one division and loki were
pretty up there as well and of course
with all of this happening everybody has
been wondering about all of these new
characters that are going to be
introduced in the marvel cinematic
universe in phase 4 phase 5 and beyond
and today i have for you a list of 10
heroes rumored to be coming to the mcu
some of them you've definitely heard by
now and some of them you have definitely
hoped for but these in particular are
backed by a decent source so let's dive
into this and if you're new be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos like i said a lot of these
have been rumored but these 10 in
particular have been talked about by the
twitter account main middleman and since
one division this account has been
pretty dang accurate in leaking things
ahead of time it was particularly
accurate in certain scenes that were in
one division so all of these heroes this
account has said are most likely coming
to the mcu sooner rather than later and
the first one that i want to start off
with is captain britain because i think
that the way the mcu was going right now
with the next upcoming films this just
makes perfect sense this makes perfect
sense because brian braddock aka captain
britain is actually part of a larger
multiversal team of captain britons
called the captain britain court in the
comics brian braddock was in a near
fatal motorcycle accident in which
merlin and his daughter the omniversal
guardian roma appear to him and they
offer him the chance to be a superhero
he is offered a choice the amulet of
right or the sword of might in which he
chooses the amulet of right this choice
transforms him into captain britain he
is then tasked with defending britain
and upholding its laws but it's later
revealed that braddock is part of a
larger interdimensional core of mystical
protectors the captain britain core as
it turns out on other versions of earth
and other universes there are other
captain britains all with the same
powers all tasked with guarding their
britain in their universe so a pretty
big multiversal character we have here
so i think that this just makes perfect
sense considering the fact that we have
a multiverse now loki set up the
multiverse spider-man no way home is
going to kind of break it open a little
bit and then in multiverse of madness
it's kind of all just going to explode
so it would make sense that a
multiversal character like captain
britain would soon join and in fact we
believe that there was an easter egg for
brian braddock or at least his father in
avengers in-game where steve is in peggy
carter's office and he overhears her
talking to another agent and they say
that there was an ancient braddock and
there was an explosion in the comics
brian braddock's mother and father did
die in an explosion so that very well
could have been an easter egg for
captain britain and fun fact captain
britain's sister is the mutant psylocke
so if he's coming i really really hope
his sister comes as well and does go on
to become psylocke the next one is nova
and i know a lot of people really want
nova to enter the mcu and i have good
news for you marvel studios president
kevin feige has confirmed that they are
going to bring nova to the mcu of course
he didn't say when he just said when the
timing is right but it sure did seem
like avengers infinity war set up nova
to make his mcu debut and i'm
particularly going to be talking about
richard ryder in the comics ramen day
the last surviving centurion of xandar
of their novacore as he's dying
transfers his powers over to richard
ryder making him nova prime i think we
have a similar situation here in the mcu
thor told the guardians of the galaxy
that thanos decimated zandar meaning
that the power of the nova corps had to
go to somebody if there is one last
living survivor or if they transferred
to somebody this could have happened in
the mcu we didn't see zandar get
decimated so we didn't see if there was
one person left or if the power simply
went to somebody on earth but you can
definitely see how it's set up for this
and since marvel is exploring the more
cosmic side of the mcu now moving
forward i'm betting that we see him
relatively soon the next hero that is
rumored to be coming is hercules now
even if you don't know marvel comics you
pretty much know who hercules is the
character is based off of the hercules
from greek mythology and pretty much has
all the same powers superhuman agility
durability endurance strength he's
pretty much thor he just doesn't have a
cool hammer he appears in many thor
comics and he appears in a very classic
story tales to astonish where he goes up
against the hulk he's also appeared with
the avengers before but was never an
official member just a guest of the
avengers considering that he was pretty
prominent in some thor comics i wouldn't
be surprised if thor love and thunder
showed us a little bit of him but that's
just a thought on my part in no way is
that a confirmation another character
that is rumored to be coming is rick
jones and this is a rather interesting
one but it actually makes sense
considering the fact that we're going to
be getting a she-hulk series in which
bruce banner is going to be a part of in
the comics rick jones is kind of why
bruce banner became the hulk long story
short rick jones accepted a dare to go
out to a bomb testing site in new mexico
where bruce banner would be testing a
bomb in which he goes out onto the site
and saves rick by pushing him into a
protective trench but bruce ends up
absorbing the gamma rays and transforms
into the hulk rick jones feeling
extremely guilty over the incident leads
him to stay close to him rick actually
formed the teen brigade which led to the
origin of the avengers rick would go on
to have weird run-ins with captain
marvel genesis vel and would later go on
to become a-bomb a hulk abomination
hybrid type thing so it'll be
interesting to see his story in the mcu
especially since we didn't get a bruce
banner hulk origin story in the mcu
perhaps rick jones has been there the
entire time but is now only coming to
the spotlight and speaking of the hulk
here's another character rumored to be
coming to the mcu that actually could
replace the hulk amadeus cho amadeus cho
is south korean and he is insanely smart
he's actually dubbed the seventh most
intelligent man in the world due to this
fact his family was tragically killed
and he went on the run for a while until
he eventually met bruce banner who
protected him eventually bruce banner
got stuck with a dangerous amount of a
new type of radiation the threat was
this could cause the hulk to melt down
and kill a ton of people so amadeus
assisted him using special nanites he
absorbed the hulk's power in which he
himself then became the hulk and he
actually kind of prided himself on being
a better and smarter hulk being able to
control his hulk persona a little bit
more however that would only remain true
for a little bit considering the fact
that xiang chi is about to release and i
think it's going to be insanely
successful as it is one of my favorite
marvel movies i definitely see marvel
introducing amadeus cho a korean
superhero especially if it's about time
for bruce banner's run as the hulk to
end now another one that i know
everybody has just been waiting for for
such a long time is ghost rider ghost
rider has been rumored to be coming to
the mcu for a little bit now with rumors
stating that he could be making his mcu
debut in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and let's be
honest pretty much everything is fair
game in that movie and it is supposed to
be a horror type mcu film so ghostwriter
appearing would make sense it's also
rumored that a midnight suns movie could
be in development right now over at
marvel studios in which ghost rider
would definitely be a part of that group
and another character that would
actually fit very well is werewolf by
night now in the past few days it has
been reported that marvel is developing
a halloween special for disney plus
based off of werewolf by night so
werewolf by night is seemingly confirmed
to enter the mcu for a halloween special
in 2022 werewolf by night is jacob
rusoff who would later go on to become
jack russell when his mother would
remarry his father was a werewolf and
when he turned 18 the curse struck him
too making him become a werewolf on full
moons where he had absolutely no control
over himself however mysterious beings
known as the three who are all partially
lifted the curse and they made it to
where he could change on demand and when
he was the werewolf he still had his
human intellect so this would definitely
be a pretty good character to join the
midnight suns then we have another very
interesting character rumored to be
coming to the mcu and that is kazar
khazar has a very interesting story his
father actually discovered anti-metal
which was later determined to be an
isotope of vibranium and his father
discovered this in a hidden jungle in
antarctica known as the savage land his
mother died and him and his father would
go on to the savage land where his
father would end up being killed the man
apes were about to kill him as well but
then they were attacked by zaboo the
last of its species of a saber-toothed
tiger zaboo then took him in and kazaar
was raised by a saber-toothed tiger but
what is really interesting is that the
x-men actually go looking for khazar
because they believe him to have mutant
powers when the x-men get there some of
them end up getting captured by the
man-apes in which khazar and zaboo end
up helping free them from there he would
go on to be an ally of the x-men
spider-man and daredevil and plenty more
so i would really really be curious to
see what type of storyline they have for
khazar in the mcu but another character
that is rumored to come actually does
have a connection with kazar and that is
dr theodore salas dr ted salas was
essentially trying to create the super
soldier serum 2.0 however his wife would
betray him and aim would attack him and
in an attempt to get away and save
himself he injected himself with a serum
that combined with the mystical powers
of the swamp turned him into man thing
not knowing is hulkling teddy rufus aka
hulkling is a cree scroll hybrid his
father was actually captain marvel a
cree and his mother was a skrull
princess annelle now teddy is actually
super powerful because he got the best
of both worlds the cree and the skrull
and due to this he has insane strength
and he can shapeshift and this will
definitely be a super cool character for
the young avengers to have on their team
so those are 10 new characters rumored
to come to the mcu sooner than later be
sure to let me know what you think about
these characters in the comments down
below and let me know which character
you are most excited to see don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
[Music]
you